[Music]
how are you eddie
hi i'm doing good uh i just have a quick
question
um
i
i i'm on babysit number five and we've
my wife and i read your book we have two
kids
um
we're just kind of stuck in a college
fund
you know we believe and i know there's
studies showing like you know sometimes
kids that just get handed you know
their
you know money or just pay for stuff um
oftentimes it ends up hurting them more
because they get a freebie um
reading your book i don't really feel
like i got a clear
direction of why
to to have a college fund kids
you know why we would uh
why we would look for a call and party
proposes attacking them
so you're saying you would prefer that
that that not to furnish any money for
your kids college and for them to pay
for their own because you're afraid
you're that when kids are handed money
you're going to ruin them
eventually like to have them something
so i don't want an inheritance but i
don't want to give it to them right when
they get out of high school or you know
or something they want them to work for
it
how old are your kids
and then one's uh six months
i'm sorry your phone broke up six months
and what
years
two years okay
all right still little well there's
nothing wrong with what you're saying if
you want to go that route i've got a
friend who is a professional football
player and uh
he his school was paid for because he
went to college on a football
scholarship and he's a you know he grew
up in a real hardcore blue-collar
household and he had to work for
everything and he said his kids are
going to work or they're going to get a
scholarship they're going to figure it
out he'll help him show him how to do it
but he's not giving him a dime
and
he's real hardcore on that and if you
want to be that that's okay there's
nothing wrong with that
the vast majority of people that we work
with want to help fund their kids
college one way or the other
the uh and that's why the baby step is
there we did fund our kids college and
uh
we did not ruin our children in the
process
uh yeah so the uh you know the the
i think that that
you know the thing i would think on from
a parenting standpoint i'm not arguing
with you you're welcome to do what
you're talking about there's nothing
wrong with what you're talking about
okay but the reason that i went a
different direction was i discovered
that my children turning out to have a
work ethic
and have integrity and have character uh
didn't have as much to do with how much
money i gave them as how i made them
behave
yeah it's true and so my kids know how
to knew how to work before they went to
college work ethic was required in our
household i'm a hard-working guy and i
believe in hard work the harder i work
the luckier i get you know and that kind
of stuff i i'm that guy you know so uh
our kids had jobs they had jobs at the
house they had chores they had to do
they got paid for the chores some of
them some of them they did just because
you love your mother shut up and you
help your mother right and so we did
some of that and we mixed it up and and
so and and they're getting help for
college was contingent upon them
behaving
if they weren't going to behave
uh
correctly then you know you're not gonna
be out here playing beer pong and uh you
know sleeping around all over the place
and you know this is not a chance for
you to try to show out all the stupid
human tricks in one four year period of
time me fund it
you know so we're not doing that either
so the the gift for college was
contingent upon
that but by the time they got to college
it was not really a probability they
were going to do that because we'd
already handled those behavior issues
long before college
those people that show out usually
weren't taught to behave long before
college
or they're clamped down on so hard that
was the first time they ever were
allowed to have their own thoughts
uh and they blow up at college one of
the two
so uh
you know that's just kind of a parenting
discussion we can have
but but at the end of that discussion if
you still say
hey i'm not giving them a dime the
little turkeys are going to work for it
i'm not going to be mad about that
i will challenge you that it's a big
bill and you need to show them a method
to get to be able to pay for it
teach them entrepreneurial skills so
they can start their own run their own
business while they're in school make
good money not be flopping whoppers and
hope they can get through school
teach them about selecting an
inexpensive school
because they're not going to have much
money to go to school with
teach them about getting scholarships
teach them about getting good grades to
get good scholarships and being good
citizens to get good scholarships and
teach them some of the methodology like
we have in the ramsey book debt-free
degree
you should coach them if you're not
especially if you're not going to give
them money
but there's no moral requirement that
says you have to pay for your children's
college or you're a bad parent
and on the other hand if you do pay for
your kids college it doesn't say you're
necessarily a bad parent either that
somehow you allowed them to be trust
fund babies with no sense of dignity
identity or personal responsibility
those things should be taught
independent of money
the money then should the way they
handle money should be the result of the
character you grow in them as a dad and
as a mom really good discussion man
thank you for calling in with that